Hey guys!, i'm Nate welcome back to the workshop not too long ago
We made a video showing you how to make a copy of a vinyl record using a silicone mold and some resin i used two
types of resin for that experiment the first of which i didn't put in a vacuum chamber
Because i explained that it cured so quickly it wouldn't have time to de gas off the bubbles
well that made a lot of you curious i guess
Because several people commented saying that they wanted to see what happens if we put that resin in the vacuum chamber so that's what we're
gonna
try out today!
we've got my quick setting two-part resin
We'll pour it off into a cup mix it up and then we'll put it in the vacuum chamber and see what happens if we
let it cure while it's in a vacuum
we have our vacuum chamber and we have our resin so let's get started i'll be mixing up our residents and clear plastic cups with
Some popsicle sticks and i also have these paper plates which i've cut to fit inside our vacuum chamber these are gonna go down at
the bottom of the vacuum chamber that's just in case any of our resins fills up over the edges of the cup it won't bond
permanently to the glass of our vacuum chamber it'll just be stuck to these disposable paper plates instead
cups should balance
Nicely in the middle of that and hopefully if we do have any spillage it'll land on the plate and not on the glass
to start with for our equal amounts of each half of our resin now before i put these in a vacuum chamber just as an
Example so we can see what changes let's just pour one half into the other mix it up and let it cure in the cups
this is actually quite a lot of this resin to have in one cup it's very thick at this point and it's not usually
Designed to cast quite this thick we're gonna see what happens anyway
Now that should just take a few minutes and then it'll start to solidify it'll get gelatinous and then turn hard
feeling on the sides it will also usually warm up as it catalyzes
They'll be able to tell when the process is starting is the whole cup and start to get toast
Looking down into it there are a lot of tiny little bubbles so the vacuum chamber really might do quite a bit too
for a honey consistency in this of a boil consistency oh now it's more of a molasses consistency
It's getting very hot oh wow and there you go now it's
thickened up so much but it's not really even dripping off the popsicle stick anyway
There you have it that is now?
catalyzed it is no longer liquid it's still curing it's still very warm and it's still fairly soft like it's a
spongy sort of solid at this point it will eventually get
To the point where it's completely
solid just a hard plastic resin now we know what it looks like if we don't put it in a vacuum chamber
let's try it in the vacuum
I'm gonna have to move fairly quickly so we'll pour 1/2 of the resin into the other stir it up and then put it into
The vacuum chamber throw the lid on and get pulling a vacuum as quickly as possible here goes oh?
There we go we've got like a foam forming on the surface now
most of the bubbles have broken at this point
so we're looking like we just have a
resin that's mostly degassed
It is still bubbling a lot so it's not degassed yet
it's kind of a race will it solidify first or will the gas all get pulled out of it first
there are still some bubbles coming out but the bubbles on the surface
don't really look like they're moving and popping very much
so i think our resin has probably started to cure already i
think that's it i
think our resin is no longer liquid
couple little bubbles on the surface looked like they popped but for the most part that foam just sort of stayed in place where it
was
look at this
Is nice and warm i'd say it's definitely started to cure down here in our cup we have this gelatinous
bubble foam on top
you, can see it's cured these bubbles don't pop but they are a little bit squishy i
hope that demonstrates pretty well why i didn't try to degassed
This type of resin before i used it to cast a record by the time it's pulled all of the air out
the resin has already set and you can't pour it into the mold anymore there is a
variation on this experiment that i want to try a while back i was playing around with what
different chemicals you could mix it together because that's my hobby
and i tried mixing some of this resin with a little bit of clear elmer's glue and the result i got was pretty surprising
Now as a comparison remember this is what happens with the normal resin when there is no glue added to it
let's watch
hasn't cured completely yet but it is getting there it's not liquid it doesn't fall out of the cup
Pretty close so let's try mixing up our same combination of resin with glue in it and see what happens if we have this reaction
in a vacuum
Oh, we have a fast expansion now
Maybe, too fast to the lack of pressure is just making it all destabilizing bubble
there goes up and out this is why we have the plate
just, kind of a bubbling foam red all over
the bubbling does seem to be slowing down i don't know if that means the reaction is slowing down
Or if it means that the reaction is getting near the end and all of the bubbles are actually starting to harden in place
There we go i think at this point our resin has probably cured most of the way so let's add pressure back in and see
what happens to those bubbles that have already formed
not, a lot of change
there we go it's still somewhat soft but it's just all made up of bubbles is just like a
gelatinous phone almost at this point i don't know if i'll be able to get out from under the bubbles in this one so on
there we go
barely any resin stayed in our cup almost all of it bubbled out
It spilled out all over onto our plate to make me very glad that i thought to put a plate in there
other than that yeah we just have this
sort of plastic feed
sort of squishy foam going on
interesting stuff glad we didn't try making your record out of this i don't think you would have played no ball
So if it's obviously sticking
To the plate quite a bit and i can't get it off but i can peel off sort of the top layer that's
one heck of a texture it's just made of
Bubbles really collapsed bubbles most of them popped as soon as
we added pressure back in
There we have it a whole bunch of?
Varieties of what happens with this resin if we put it in the vacuum chamber we have our standard unvaccinated
We have the same resin put into a vacuum chamber and we got some good bubbling action on the top it's
solidified with all sorts of gaps and polls in it
Showing why we didn't try to vacuum it before we cast our record with it we then have the resin mixed with a little bit
Of clear elmer's glue which makes it foam up and bubbling bizarrely so we get this very lightweight
low-density resin and then when we take that same combination we put that in the vacuum chamber it actually bubbles so
aggressively that it just comes right up out of the cup spills all over and doesn't hold itself together
nearly as well i hope you have enjoyed these tests of our resin in a vacuum chamber and mixed with some glue if you have
some other ideas of things you want to see us try let us know down in the comments thanks for joining us for this video
today and remember to come gear yourself up with hats shirts another cool merch at the king of random comm see you there
arian they are a little bit squishy
See you there?
hey guys did you know that we're on twitter instagram and facebook
As well all at the king of random and every platform has a different purpose
So go scroll through the histories check out what we're doing